TOM SCOTT: The Youth Winter Olympic Games
have brought me over to Lillehammer, in Norway.
It's still early in the season here,
so they are making snow.
Because getting these slopes to competition
standard isn't easy.
ROGER HJELMSTADSTUEN: Here in Hafjell we have
about 250 snow guns
They're all controlled from a big control
room
and they all are connected together.
It's a lot about planning. To put the guns
at the right place.
It's about wind, if you put it on the wrong
side it's going to be a lot of snow in the
trees.
That's why we have two teams working night
and day
the whole fall, the whole winter, to make
sure everything is perfect.
TS: Here, in the snow gun, huge amounts of
water and air
are being forced through tiny nozzles,
creating a fine mist that freezes into fresh
powder.
But while the weather is cold,
the temperature is actually not quite below
freezing here.
So why does this water freeze into snow?
Why doesn't it just... rain?
Okay. Physics.
As water evaporates, it sucks heat from the
surrounding environment.
Put some water on your hand and blow on it,
and the wet part will feel colder
because that evaporating water is sucking
the heat away from your body.
That's what's going on here.
Some of these water droplets evaporate,
so they drop the temperature around them.
Which means other droplets might start to
freeze.
And once that's started, you get what are
called nucleation sites:
the start of snowflakes.
And if it's not quite working efficiently
enough,
then you can buy a kind of protein slurry.
You add it, very diluted to the water,
and suddenly every droplet is a nucleation
site
and can form its own snowflake.
RH: To make snow, we have pipes for water
and pipes for air.
On top of that, every cannon needs a computer
cable.
The water here in Hafjell comes from big lakes
at the top of the mountain
and from there it's natural pressure going
down.
That's the easiest and least expensive way.
During a normal season, we use about 30,000
litres a minute.
It sounds a lot, but we have a big, big lake
so during the whole season it's about 5-10cm
down
and that's if no new water is coming in
so most of the time, it just looks like it's
not touched.
TS: The drier the air is, the more water can
evaporate into it.
So if the air is really, really dry, 0% humidity,
you can make proper snow when the air temperature
is well above freezing, anything up to 6°C.
But if the air is humid, there is nowhere
for those droplets to evaporate to.
At 100% humidity, when the air is saturated,
the temperature has to be -2 or lower to make
snow.
'Cos this isn't some kind of instant magic
freezer.
The laws of thermodynamics pretty much make
that impossible.
Much as it'd be great to have a snow gun that
works in the middle of summer
all you're going to end up with then...
...is a rainmaker.
RH: So, snowmaking is really important for
big contests,
but it's also really important for just
the average day here in Hafjell with normal
people.
It's what we need to make this mountain work.
Without it we'd be nothing. We need snow!
TS: There's a load more videos over on the
Olympics channel
and on my channel, go check 'em out, go subscribe,
and thank you to the Youth Winter Olympic
Games
for bringing me out here to Lillehammer.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]